what is the lowest IQ esport out there
maybe from the ones that I really know
maybe rocket League it just seems very
routine to me valerant they ain't going
to like that CS goo but reskinned anime
characters OverWatch yeah it's
unfortunately OverWatch what it's
probably like fortnite it's definitely
fortnite yeah just a battle royale just
a battle royale he says I'm keeping my
lips sealed tight for this one I played
the
fifth oh which fan base do I want to
insult I'm going to say rocket League
you don't have to have an i a high IQ to
understand everything that's happening
in the game car goes fast car explodes
car hits ball into net it's probably
going to be some mobile game I I don't I
I couldn't even name one for you is
Candy Crush in esport I don't know
something like that something very basic
and easy would be like the lowest IQ
esport I see what you're trying to do
here over rocket League I never played
it before so I just had to throw an eort
out there I'm going to be honest with
you sorry for the rocket league players
sorry you're sorry